welcome to pftot on yahoo sports peter
king mike florio here getting you ready
for the division around the playoffs and
peter three of the teams are big
underdogs the titans going to baltimore
the vikings going to san francisco and
the texans returning to arrowhead
stadium to take on the chiefs even
though the texans won during the regular
season the chiefs are heavy favorites in
this one of those three
which do you think is the most likely to
advance to the conference championship
game
what if i said zero
[Laughter]
no i think
you know as i look at this field right
now one of the things that i find most
interesting and i'm going to take the
minnesota vikings but one of the things
i find that's most interesting about it
is that
the vikings have so many elements in
place
that you know to play a really good road
playoff game here's what they have in
place they have a tremendous defensive
front
uh which we saw over the weekend how it
can wreak havoc with drew brees jimmy
garoppolo playing his first nfl playoff
game
is this is a huge factor this pass rush
against garoppolo number two
they have a a secondary that played
better in this game than it had played
this year
seems like it's a little bit healthier
and the added bonus of having very good
linebackers in coverage to do battle
with george kittle number three
they have one of the top five running
games in football right now
they need you know bill cower used to
always say this mike
about going on the road with the
pittsburgh steelers he said we are
always a big game for the team that we
went into to play and so i always used
to tell the players you've got to
withstand the storm right at the
beginning and that crowd in santa clara
is going to be huge early on so the
vikings whether they're playing defense
or offense has got to take the crowd out
of the game early the way you do that is
with a running game that gets some first
downs and with a front seven that forces
a couple of punts on the first two
series of the 49ers look if i had to go
to vegas and bet five bucks on this game
give me san francisco
but with those three options i will take
the minnesota vikings i think they are
most playoff ready to play a really good
game this weekend
and you know peter there was a time when
the teams that earned the buys were much
more vulnerable in the divisional round
than they are now in recent years those
teams are more likely to advance but
that that rest period
and you're playing a team that has a
jolt of confidence coming from winning
in the wild card round and i think that
victory over the saints does wonders for
kirk cousins and his teammates in
minnesota and if you can catch them
wobbly early if you get them with a
surprise left hook that can change
everything because the pressure is on
the 49ers there is no pressure on the
vikings they're supposed to lose they're
the sixth seed they should already be
home the 49ers are the ones who have
earned that spot where everyone is
expecting them to advance and i could
see the vikings give him a hard time i
also could see the titans giving the
ravens everything that they can handle
because that's going to be a close game
and if it's a close game you know it's
more likely that the one seed is the one
that seizes up in the fourth quarter
realizing we're supposed to win this
game and this could still go either way
and i really do feel like it's much more
of a toss-up than the other games
because it's going to be old school
football it's going to be grinded out
it's gritty and dirty the way the titans
like it and it's the way the ravens do
it and i could see that game going
either way
mike two points number one i do not
remember a year
with two six seeds that are as
threatening as these two six seeds
look at these two games coming up the
six at the one
is it a gimme for either one not at all
and it should be shouldn't it shouldn't
a 14 and two team playing at home off a
buy have a gimme game
they should but they're not going to and
the second thing is this has the feel
of an ncaa tournament game a basketball
tournament game 2 versus 15. the
tennessee titans are 15. they're the mid
major team in the mid-american
conference that can go in and wreak
havoc in this tournament
all right for more pftot on yahoo sports
videos check us out throughout the post
season
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports